under capitalism the only way Capital  could be generated could be produced was  when a capitalist had workers working  for her or him through the production of  surplus value and amount of that Surplus  value was reinvested into capital goods  so the only way Capital could breed was  through the labor market through the  manufacturing that was taking place  using wage labor at the factory in the  office in the supermarket but what I'm  saying here is that the cloudlist having  a power that no capitalist ever had they  have the power to make you and I unwaged  without even realizing that we're  working for them produce part of their  command Capital every time we move  around with our phone that has Google  Maps on it Google Maps knows where we  are that increases the command capital  of Google so we are contributing  directly Capital without us being waged  or part of the labor process at all this  is a new power the capitalists never had